[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
وهذه
العقيقه
بانظمه دفاع جويه
فرنسا تقلل من قيمه الرد الايرانيه على
العقوبات الاوروبيه وتعتبر ان النظام غارق
بحالته
العماليه تتحدى الحكومه وتنفذ اكبر اضراب
في البلاد منذ عشر سنوات
[موسيقى]
ايضا
تيك توك من نوع اخر مؤسسه انستقرام
يطلقاني التطبيقا جديدا يعد بموجز اخباريا
مخصص قائم على احدث تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعيه
[موسيقى]
منذ ساعات على قرار الفيدرالي الامريكي
ويبدو انه الاتجاه تم بالفعل بالرفع
القليل وليس الرفع الكبير ومعنا الاسواق
كانت منتظره لكي تعرف اذا ما كان
الفيدرالي الامريكي سيلمح الى ان هذه
الزيادات في الفائده ستستمر ام انها
ستتوقف اي سياسه تسديد النقل ستستمر ام لا
الفيراري اذا الامريكي الان يقرر رفع
الفائده بصفر فاصل 25% 25 نقطه اساسا
بالمئه طبعا هذه ليست المره الاولى التي
يرفع فيها الفيدرالي الامريكي اسعار
الفائده اكثر من مره
اعتقد بالسعه القادمه سنستمع ونسمع اخبار
العديد من الدول التي ترفع فائده الاسعار
لانه لديها ارتباط بالدولار الامريكي اذا
نحن سنقع ايضا على هذا الموضوع مع رفع
اسعار الفائده الذي كان متوقعا وهو فقط ب
25 نقطه اساس بخمسه وعشرين نقطه اساس
وليصل الى
4.75 بالمئه اذا ومن الممكن ان يكون هناك
رفع اخر او مرات رفع متتاليه لاحقه او لا
بحسب حجم السيطره او مدى السيطره على
التضخم وهذا ما سنعرفه لاحقا
الى التطورات المتسارعه التي تشهدها الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا فما كان ممنوعا على
كياف من اسلحه امس اصبح متاحا اليوم ونقصد
هنا الدبابات وربما المقاتلات دخل على خط
الازمه مصرحا في حديث نسيان انه يدرس دعم
اوكرانيا بانظمه دفاع جوي وانه يجرى
مراجعه لسياسه بلاده بشان دعم اوكرانيا
ويوما بعد يوم ينخرط الغرب اكثر في هذه
الحرب وينتقل من امدادك بالاسلحه الى
التدريب ايضا واوروبا ستعلن عن هدفها
الجديد في الحرب مسؤول اوروبي رفيع
المستوى اكد ان جوزيف بوري سيعلن خلال
القمه الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه يوم الثالث من
فبراير عن خطه لتدريب 30 الف جندي اوكراني
وكان الهدف الاولي هو تدريب 15000 جندي
بينما سيكون الهدف الجديد هو 15000 اخر اي
سيبلغ المجموع 30 الف جندي بشكل عام في
اللقاء المرتقب ايضا قضيه انضمام اوكرانيا
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وخطاه السلام للرئيس
الاوكراني لحل النزاع ومساعده المجتمع
لكياف فضلا عن الامن الغذائي المجتمع
الدولي طبعا والتي ستكون في الثالث من
فبراير في كييف اذا ويبدو ان اوروبا يا
طاهر تستعد لما بعد اوكرانيا عبر دعم
الناتو لكن موسكو تدرك ذلك جيدا وتستعد هي
الاخرى لجميع الاحتمالات رئيسه لاستخبارات
العسكريه الروسيه
قال ان حلف الناتو يزيد الرهان في
اوكرانيا لانه مازال يحلم بهزيمه روسيا
استراتيجيا منتقا وعوده واشنطن الاخيره
لكاب بتقديم مزيدا من المساعدات العسكريه
لها هذه المساعدات ربما سيشرف عليها بايضا
عن قرب بعدما اعلن الرئيس البولندي بانه
يتوقع زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
لدول وسط اوروبا خلال شهر فبراير الجاري
بالطبع نتوقع زياره رئيس جو بايدن لسبب
بسيط للغايه وهو انه تم بالفعل الاعلان
عنها من المرجح ان ياتي الرئيس الى الجزء
الخاص بنا من اوروبا في فبراير اريد فقط
ان اؤكد على شيء واحد الجزء الخاص بنا من
اوروبا يعني اوروبا الوسطى مع اخذ ذلك في
الاعتبار بانني افترض ان الجزء الخاص بنا
من اوروبا في هذا السياق هو منطقه تمتد من
رومانيا الى استونيا
السخاء الغربي مع اوكرانيا راويه يتواصل
فبعد حسم ملف الدبابات باعطاء الضوء
الاخضر لارسالها تسير واشنطن المزيد من
المساعدات قريبا هذه المساعدات ستكون
مختلفه هذه المره حيث تضم للمره الاولى
اسلحه لطالما طالبتك في الحصول عليها وهي
الصواريخ الابعد مدى فالولايات المتحده
بصدد تجهيز حزمه مساعدات جديده تبلغ
قيمتها مليارين ومئتين مليون دولار على ان
يتم الاعلان عنها رسميا في وقت لاحق من
هذا الاسبوع وذلك نقلا عن مسؤول امريكي
حزمه قد تشمل ايضا معدات دعم لانظمه
الدفاع الجوي باتريوت وذخائر دقيقه
التوجيه وصواريخ جاب لينا المضاده
للدبابات وفيما يتعلق بالصواريخ ذات المدى
الابعد فان الامر يتعلق بالصواريخ معينه
تحديدا هي تعني همم يعني القطر الصغير هي
ارض جو ذات قطر صغير وهي صواريخ تصنعها
شركه بوينج ويتم اطلاقها من راجيمات
الصواريخ مثل هاي مارس ويتم توجيهها
بواسطه نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي ولكن
طبعا البعد اكبر ويمكنها التغلب على
التشويش الالكترونيه كما يمكن استخدامها
في جميع الظروف المناخيه ويبلغ مداها 150
كم ولها قدرات على المناوره والالتفاف
طبعا الفرق بين هاي مارس 80 كم وهذه
الابعد مدى ب 150 كلم وبفضل هذه الصواريخ
ستصبح اوكرانيا قادره على ضربه اهداف
لم تكن تصلها من قبل
في اوكرانيا يرتفع سقف المساعدات العسكريه
لاول مره حزمه مساعدات الامريكيه جديده
لاوكرانيا
صواريخ طويله المدى
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه الاوكرانيا
تشمل معدات دعم لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
باترون
[موسيقى]
المضاده للدبابات
من المتوقع ان تشمل المساعدات ايضا
المركبات المقاومه للالغام وانظمه اطلاق
الصواريخ المتعدده الموجهه والذخيره
تبلغ قيمه تلك المساعدات مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار
هذه المره فان الحزن القادمه ستتضمن ايضا
دعما طبيا من خلال كميه كبيره من المعدات
التي تكفي لتجهيز ثلاثه ميدانيه ولحد الان
فان البيت الابيض لم يعلن رسميا عن هذه
الحزمه التي قد يتغير محتواها قبل ان يوقع
عليها الرئيس الامريكي بنفسه وكما هو
الحال عندما يتعلق الامر باي حزمه مساعدات
غربيه فان روسيا تمدد هذه المره ايضا بهذا
الدعم الذي سيؤجج الحرب على حد وصفها
الكرام لان قال ايضا ان تسليما الولايات
المتحده صواريخ ابعد مدى الى اوكرانيا لن
يغيره مسار الاحداث واكد في الوقت نفسه
عزما القوات الروسيه مواصله هجومها مهما
كلفه العمر
حول
اوكرانيا بالسلاح نحن لا نقسم الدول وفق
مبدا الجغرافيا ما نقول ان جميع الدول
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجب ان تفهم
اننا سنعتبر هذه الاسلحه اهداف المشروعه
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه
مال المعلومات المتوفره الان حول
المساعدات العسكريه الجديده التي ستقدمها
واشنطن الى كاف وبالتحديد الصواريخ
الصواريخ الاب بعد المدى هذه المره
لو عندنا خطوه الى الوراء وشاهدنا ما
قدمته الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى
الاوكرانيين من قذائف نرى انه خلال بدايه
الصيف كانوا يعطونا الاوكرانيين قذائف تصل
الى مسافه 50 كيلو ثم هذا ذهبوا الى المئه
كيلو الان يعطونهم صواريخ تستطيع ان تغطي
ال150 كيلو اي ان الاوكرانيين سوف يتمكنون
ينضرب كل المواقع التي احتلتها القوات
الروسيه على اراضي اوكرانيا الاضافه هنا
هو انها بعض الصواريخ من الممكن ايضا ان
يصل الى جزيره القرب المقصود من هذه
الدفعات هذا التفصيل المهم جدا هو انها
الاوكرانيين سوف يتمكنون من ضرب مراكز
القياده والسيطره للقوات الروسيه وبالتالي
تعطيل ايه امكانيات للهجوم وايضا تعطيل
الدفاعات تمهيدا لهجوم من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه هذه هي الحكمه من هذه الحزمه
من المساعدات العسكريه ابقى معنا تحول الى
عبد الجواد الرشد الان ونستفيد من وجودك
معنا بادئ ببدء لنسالك عن الخبر الذي
اوردناه قبل قليل عن اكسيوس عن مسؤول
اسرائيلي يقول نبحث في مساعده اوكرانيا
ولكن دون احداث خلاف مع روسيا يعني وفق
السرديه الروسيه الرسميه على الاقل منذ
بدايه الحرب وحتى الان فيما يتعلق
باسرائيل ما مدى معقوليه ذلك
مساء الخير طاهر يعني القراءه العسكريه في
البلاد تتحدث اليوم عن ان موسكو ستقوم
باستهداف جميع الاسلحه التي قد يزود بها
الغرب او قد تقوم اسرائيل بتزويد تاكيد
بها مهما كانت انظمه للدفاع الجوي او
مقاتلات او طبعا صواريخ بعيده المدى موسكو
حتى هذه اللحظه تتحدث عن ان ااه الدفع
الكبير لهذا السلاح المتطور لن يغير من
اهداف موسكو في العمليه العسكريه وهي
ذاهبه نحو تحقيق اهدافها لكن طبعا طاهر
وراويه لا يمكن اخفاء قلق موسكو من
الصواريخ بعيده المدى كما تحدث همم يعني
الزميل بان هذه الصواريخ تتصل الى مناطق
قريبه من شبه جزيره القرمو هناك مراكز
قياده هناك مطارات عسكريه قد تتعرض لضربات
وهنا موسكو تعول بشكل كبير على انظمه
دفعها الجويه طبعا خرج اليوم هو تحدث عن
ضروره عدم الوصول بالوضع
لمرحله تلقي المناطق الروسيه وهنا يدور
الحديث على ما يبدو عن شبه جزيره القرم
بضربات اوكرانيه واولى هذه المهمه لوزاره
دفاعه في القيام بصداع هذه الضربات
المرحله كما ترى موسكو مقدمه على عمليه
تصعيد كبيره طبعا مع ضخ هذا السلاح الكبير
طبعا جميع القراءات السياسيه والعسكريه في
البلاد ترى في ضخ المقاتلات والدبابات
والصواريخ بعيده المدى بانه تصعيد كبير
وليس مدمن عمر الازمه كان هناك حديث عن
زياره للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
اوروبا هل من تاكيد حول هذه الزياره
ليس هناك تاكيد بعد على ان الرئيس
الامريكي سوف يذهب الى اوروبا او الى
بولندا ولكن هناك الكثير من المؤشرات
وهناك الكثير من المطالبات ايضا من ان
يكون الرئيس الامريكي في اوروبا المطلوب
هو ان يثبت الرئيس
الامريكيين اولا وللاوكرانيين ثانيا ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقف مع
اوكرانيا في هذه المعركه الى حين تحرير كل
الاراضي ما يريده الاوروبيون وخصوصا هذا
ما عبر عنه مستشار المانيا هو ان تؤكد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقوفها الى
جانب الاوروبيين واوكرانيا حتى نهايه
المعركه
عبد الجواد هناك يعني تصريحات جديده
لوزراء اوكرانيين من وزاره الدفاع يعني
لنائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يتحدث عن
الخسائر الروسيه ولكن عن المحاولات
الروسيه الحديثه في بعض المناطق لكسر حاله
الجمود المعطيات من اجانب الروسي بشان اخر
التطورات الميدانيه على الارض ان كان هناك
في انجازات حقيقيه او اا تراجعات وخسائر
كبرى
طاهر يعني على ما يبدو من الانباء الوارده
من هناك بان هناك تخبط في التصريحات طبعا
خرجت اليوم حكومه دانيسكو وتحدثت عن ان
القوات الروسيه تحكم القبضه والسيطره على
الكثير من المناطق في ضخمه الا ان طبعا
قائد مجموعه فاجنر خرج من ذو نحو ساعه من
الان وتحدث عن ان قوات موسكو طبعا او
القوات الروسيه لا تسيطر على كافه المحاور
في باخمود طبعا في احدث الاخبار طبعا
الوارده من دنيه هناك سيطره للقوات
الروسيه على قريه تقع في تلك المنطقه طبعا
ليس لها اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره الا انها
تاتي ضمن طبعا تحركات موسكو في التقدم
طبعا ضخمه المعركه الكبرى من التقارير
والخرائط التي نشرتها وزاره الدفاع اليوم
يظهر الوضع بشكل كبير وهو انشاء خط دفاعي
من قبل موسكو وكوفيه في تلك المناطق يتحس
كبيره هي تغير في طريقه العمليه العسكريه
الحديث كان يدور عن ضربات كانت تستخدمها
موسكو ومن ثم التحرك ميدانيا لكن على ما
يبدو الان ان معركه الارض هي ستكون
الفاصله خلال طبعا الايام او الاسابيع
وهذا ما يتحدث عنه تحديدا نائب وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني الان يقول رغم الخسائر
الثقيله الا ان القوات الروسيه تتابع في
عمليتها في بخموت وافديافكا ويقول ان
القوات الروسيه تتفوق عليهم
بالعدد والعتاد اضافه الى الخبر العاجل
ايضا عن اليمان معارك عنيفه تحصل هناك
وتحديدا بالشرق والقوات الروسيه تحاول خرق
خطوط دفاعاتنا في لبنان هذا ما تقوله
الدفاع الاوكرانيه شكرا
من موسكو مراسلنا شكرا جزيلا لك وكذلك
اعلنت سلطات دنيتك الماليه لروسيا اكمال
تطويق الجيش الروسي لمدينه محمود شمال
مقاطعه دونياتسك من النواحي الشرقيه
والجنوبيه والشماليه في موضوع مرتبط اذهب
الاخبار العاجله
المناطق الجنوبيه من المدينه قتال الشوارع
بين [__] فاجنر والجيش الاوكراني رائد
الاخبار يسلط الضوء على الاوضاع العسكريه
تحديدا في بخمه من دنياز
ما زالت الاعمال العسكريه مستمره في جنوب
وشرق اوكرانيا وما زالت مقاطعه دان
يستشهدوا اعنف المعارك على الاطلاق تزامنا
مع وصوله امداداتهم عسكريه من روسيا لا
سيما بعد اعلان موسكو عن التعبئه الجزئيه
اواخر العامل الماضي فشمال المقاطعه
يشهدوا تقدما للقوات الروسيه على الاراضي
التي سيطر عليها الجيش الاكراني سابقا
وقوته فاجنر
على مزيد من الاراضي والبلدات حول مدينه
باخبط بعد ان اكملت السيطره على جوانبها
الثلاثه وتقطع الامدادات عن المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين المحاصرين داخل المدينه من
الطرق السريعه المؤديه من الناحيه الغربيه
الى مدينه
اختراقه مدينه فاخمط من الناحيه الجنوبيه
حيث تنطلق العمليات العسكريه من مدينه
كلشفكه وصولا الى مدينه ايفانكا وتتقدم
القوات الروسيه من شمال باخمود نحو مدينه
سيفرسك التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني
بعد سيطرهم على مدينتين لقداتنا وسوليدار
ومزيد من البلدات لقناتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاغبر دنيا
الفرنسيه
يغرق في حاله من الانكار ونظريه المؤامره
وقالت الوزيره الفرنسيه ان العقوبات التي
قال النظام الايراني انه فرضها على
الاوروبيين تدل على انه نظام يعاني من قصر
النظر واضافه ان العقوبات التي فرضتها
ايران لا يمكن ان تقارن بالعقبات التي
فرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي
قال مصدر دبلوماسيون فرنسيه التهديد
الايراني بدا ينسو اراضي اوروبا وامن
الاوروبيين واضاف المصدر الدبلوماسي ترى
سنه ايران الصاروخيه ومسيراتها من اسباب
عدم استقرار المنطقه
الفرنسي رؤيه ان المسارات الايرانيه تتسبب
ببرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
الاذريه تزداد تازما وسبب انشطه تخريبيه
قام بها ايرانيون في اذربيجان الخبر اعلنت
عنه وزاره الداخليه الاداريه التي اكدت
اعتقال 39 شخصا قاموا بتنفيذي انشطه
تخريبيه في اذربيجان تتمثل الانشطه في
الترويجي لصالح ايران على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي واساءه استخدام الحريه الدينيه
في البلاد فضلا عن تنفيذي مهمات لصالح
اجهزه الامن الايرانيه تاتي هذه العمليه
اياما قليله فقط بعد العمليه الخاصه التي
تم خلالها ضبط شبكه تابعه للمخابرات
الايرانيه في اذربيجان واعتقال سبعه اشخاص
يبدو الموضوع اكبر من مجرد عمليتين بل
يتعلقوا بحمل واسعه النطاق لكشف شبكه تجسس
ايرانيه تقول باكو ولا يبدو بان الملف قد
اغلق فزاره الداخليه الاداريه اعل هذه
الحمله المكثفه هي مستمره في باكو ومدن
اخرى في البلاد تصعيد ماكو ضد طهران تواصل
حيث اوسط وزاره الخارجيه الاثريه رعاياها
بالامتناع عن السفر الى ايران اذا لم تكن
لديهم ضروره قسوه توصيه جاءت هذه المره
على خلفيه الهجوم المسلحه على سفاره
اذربيجان في طهران والذي وقع يوم الجمعه
الماضيه هو الهجوم الذي اعاد الى الواجهه
الخلافات المتعدده بين اذربيجان وايران
ابرز هذه الخلافات اتهامه طهران لباك
وبيتاجيج ان ساعات الانفصاليه على اراضيها
من خلال الاقليه الاذريه المتواجده شمال
غرب ايران كما ان طهران تتوجه من التعاون
العسكري بين اذربيجان واسرائيل التي تعد
مزوده مهما للاسلحه الى باكو فضلا عن
تخوفها من امكانيه استخدام تل ابيب
الاراضي الاذريه للتحرك ضد
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه
لقوات الامن بايديهم العاريه
سميرا
جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه ردا على اي
احتجاج من قبل الشعب الايراني حتى
الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت القتل الوحشي
لامراه بسبب عدم ارتدائها حجاب الراس بشكل
مناسب يتهم النظام الجميع بانهم عملاء
للاجانب وانهم اعداء الاسلام يتهم النظام
حزبنا بارسال اسلحه الى داخله ايران في
الواقع يقف الشعب ضد قوات امن النظام
بايديهم العاريه
حسبه هو يمتلك قوات من البشمه
او استخدام الاسلحه في المستقبل القريب ضد
النظام
لدينا قوات بشمرقه يتم تدريبها لكننا لا
نخطط لنشرها في ايران بدلا من ذلك نحاول
مساعده الاحتجاجات المدنيه وان نكون صوتهم
في وسائل الاعلام الدوليه للتواصل مع
الامريكيين والاوروبيين والدعوه لمطالب
الشعب الايراني للشعب قضيه عادله ويجبوا
تلبيه مطالبهم لذلك ليس لدينا خطه
لاستخدام الاسلحه في المستقبل القريب نامل
على ان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه سوف تسقط مع
الاحتجاجات المدنيه الحاليه
وقت العربيه 360 ايضا
محامي بايدي يؤكد ان وزاره العدل لم تعثر
على اي وثائق سريه بعد تفتيش منزل الرئيس
في دلع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حول النصف مليون موظف
وعامل في قطاعات التعليم والنقل والخدمه
المدنيه اضرب في بريطانيا اليوم الاربعاء
بزياده الاجور وتحسين الشروط العمل بعد
فشل المفاوضات مع الحكومه التي اكدت مرارا
عدم قدرتها على سداد اي زياده تفوق نسبه
التضخم المسجله التي تفوق ال 10%
ان مطالبه نقابات غير معقوله ترشق رئيس
الحكومه رئيس سوناك وزعيم حزب العمال
المعارض الاتهامات بشان المسؤوليه عن
الاوضاع في البلاد مصطفى زارو
[تصفيق]
هو اضخم اضراب في بريطانيا منذ عشر سنوات
بينهم موظف الخدمه المدنيه والمحاضرون
الجميعون والمدرسون و سائق قطارات وداعمهم
في مسيره احتجاج شقت طريقها من وسط لندن
باتجاه مقر رئاسه الحكومه للمطالبه بتحسين
الاجور وظروف العمل من العصريات
وحتى مع زياده المطروحه فان تضخم خفض
رواتبنا
منذ فتره الوباء وعدم تقديم زياده في
الاجور ولا زياده لدعم التلاميذ الضعفاء
هو شغل الرئيسي
الاف ونقاط الاعتصام شكلها المضربون عن
العمل في مختلف القطاعات للضغط على
الحكومه التي طرحت رفع الاجور بنسبه 5%
وهو ما ترفضه النقابات في ظل نسبه التضخم
تجاوزت 10 في المئه وغلاء معيشه غير مسبوق
ريش هناك اذان الاضرابات التي اجبرت
ملايين التلاميذ على التغيب عن المدارس
وانتقد السياسه رئيس حزب العمال المنحزه
للنقابات
لمعارضه مشروع قانون يؤمن الحد الادنى من
السلامه كما سوت مع مجموعه اوقف استخداما
النفط ما المشترك بين النقابات وهذه
المجموعه كلاهما يموله هو وحزبه
زعيم المعارضه كير ستار مار من جهته لام
حزب المحافظين الحاكمه لفشله في التعاطي
مع الاضرابات
بعد 13 عاما في السلطه يريد لون حزب
العمال على فشله في ايجاد حل للاضرابات
انه امر مثير للشفقه حزب المحافظين صار
مدمنا على الفساد والفضائح
اضرابات مجدوله في عدد من القطاعات هذا
الاسبوع والاسبوع المقبل ولا مؤشر على
الغائها ما التعثر المفاوضات بين الحكومه
والنقابات
فيما تتمسك الحكومه بزياده رواتب معقوله
تقول نقابات العمال ان الاضراب مؤشر على
غضب اعضائها وتحذر من المزيد منها ما لم
تطرح الحكومه مقترحات ملموسه وذات مغزى
بشان رفع الاجور مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
ومن لندن ينضم الينا احمد ياسين عضو حزب
المحافظين البريطاني اهلا بك سيد احمد
يعني
ما المشكله في انه هذه الحكومه حكومه
ريشيسوناك لم تجد يعني حلا وسطا يرضي
النقابات ويرضي الناس التي نزلت باكبر
يعني
تظاهره انضمت كل النقابات حتى الان لماذا
لم تصل الحكومه والنقابات الى حل وسط ما
المشكله
المشكله تكمن بان مطالب نقابات العمال هي
مطالب غير واقعيه وهي مطالب يعني لا ترتبط
بالتحديات الخطيره التي تواجهها بريطانيا
من خلال ارتفاع مستوى التضخم وهذه
الاضرابات واقعيا تثير الكثير من
التساؤلات يعني اذا ترك الامر للحكومه
البريطانيه والقيام بتنفيذ خطتها بخفض
مستوى التضخم الى المستوى الذي كان عليه
قبل اندلاع فتيل الازمه الاوكرانيه
وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه بالتاكيد القدره
الشرائيه لجميع البريطانيين سوف تتحسن
وبالتالي ما تم يعني رفع اجور كافه نقابات
العمال سوف يعني يشعرون بمثل هذا الرفع
واقعيا من خلال ارتفاع القدره الشرائيه
اليهم هناك فجوه في الخزينه
بريطانيا فجوه ماليه تقدر بحوالي 40 مليار
جنيه استرليني لذلك الاولويه المطلقه
بالنسبه للحكومه البريطانيه هي العمل
الجاد لخفدي مستوى التضخم وحين يتم خفض
مستوى التضخم يعني بالتاكيد جميع
البريطانيين سوف يستفيدون من مثل هذه
الخطوه ولكن استقبال هنا هنا
من يتمكن من همم يعني اللحاق بما يريد قبل
الاخر هل ست الى اي ماده ستستطيع همم
حكومه سوناك ان تصمد امام هذه الاحتجاجات
والتظاهرات وللبات والاتهامات ايضا همم من
المعارضه
يعني حكومه ريش سوناك سوف تصمت وسوف تستمر
بتنفيذ خطتها لخفض مستوى التضخم وهذه
الخطوه بالتاكيد سوف تنعكس خيرا واجابا
على جميع البريطانيين واغلبيه البريطانيين
يدركون ادراكا واضحا اا بان هناك يعني
علاقه همم قد تكون مبيته ان صح التعبير
بين حزب العمال
وتزايد وتيره هذه الاضطرابات يجب ان يذكر
هنا بان نقابات العمال هي احد الممولين
الاساسيين لحزب العمال كذلك ايضا عندما
قدم ريشه سوناك لترحي وشرح خطته بتنفيذ
قوانين همم تحد من امكانيه القيام باضراب
قام
بمعارضه مثل هذه الخطوات ولكن عندما سئل
اذا اذا اقدمتم واصبحتم في الحكومه هل سوف
هل سوف تتعاملون على الغاء مثل هذه
القوانين حينها لم يجيب وتهرب من الاجابه
هناك علاقه مبيته بين سياسه حزب العمال
واندلاع فتيل مثل هذه الاضطرابات لان
مطالب المضربين هي بالتاكيد غير واقعيه
وسوف تؤثر بشكل مباشر على قدره الحكومه
البريطانيه لخفض مستوى التضخم بالتاكيد
اذا قامت الحكومه البريطانيه بتلبيه همم
مطالب نقابات العمال بمجملها مستوى التضخم
سوف يرتفع وكريستارما نفسه يدرك ذلك وهو
يؤيد ذلك يعني قالها مرات عديده همم في
السير بانه يؤيد سياسه الحكومه البريطانيه
بعدم قدرتها لتلبيه جميع مطالب نقابات
العمال لذلك التناقض واضح من خلال وجهه
نظر حزب العمال واغلب البريطانيين يدركون
صندوق النقد الدولي يعني قال اليوم بانه
بريطانيا ستدخل في فاقين الانكماش والتضخم
يعني معروف انه هي اكبر اقتصاد من اكبر
اقتصادات العالم على كل الاحوال شكرا
جزيلا لك على ارائك وعلى وجودك معنا اذا
من لندن احمد ياسين عضو حزب المحافظين
قلبي
[موسيقى]
اكد محامي الرئيس الامريكي
صباح اليوم ولم يتم العثور على اي وثائق
سريه خلال التفتيش واكدت وسائل الاعلام
بقضيه العثور على وثائق سريه في منزل تعود
لفتره خدمته كنائب رئيس
مؤكد انه سيتعاون مع تحقيقات رغما فيه ان
تكون الوفاء المكتشفه لديه لها طابع
السريع
[موسيقى]
الصراع على مقعد الرئاسه في الولايات
المتحده يشتعل مبكرا راويه فمن المرجح ان
تتزاحم اسماء كثيره على الترشح لهذا
المنصب الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب اول مترشحين رسميا للرئاسيات سيتعرف
قريبا على اول منافسه الرسميين الامر
يتعلق بنكهه لاسفير السابقه للامم المتحده
وحكمه ولايه كارولاين الجنوبيه التي تخطط
للاعلان عن ترشحها لتكون بذلك اول منافس
جمهوري معلن لترامب نقلا عن صحيفه واشنطن
الصحيفه كشفت ايضا
عن ترشحها بطريقه لافته للانظار من خلال
مقطع فيديو وذلك رغبه منها في زياده
الحماس حول هذا الحدث وبحسب الاخبار
الوارده فان هي اللي اختارت مدينه
تشارليستن بي كارولاين الجنوبيه للاعلان
عن الترشح على ان يتم ذلك في منتصف الشهر
الجاري
ترشح هيلي ينظر من الان بصراع محتدم بين
الجمهوريين لسيامه وان ترامب الذي كان
يتوقع ان تكون طريقه نحو الترشح مفروشه
سيجد امامه منافسين اخرين منهم من يتوفر
على حظوظ قائمه ياتي في طليعه هذه الاسماء
جندي سانتس حاكم ولايه فلوريدا الذي
ارتفعت شعبيته بشكل كبير بين الجمهوريين
في جميع انحاء الولاده خلال العامين ونصف
العامه الماضي كما بات يوصف داخل الاوساط
السياسيه بالوجه الجديد للحزب الجمهوري بل
ومستقبل الاسم الاخر قد يكون منافسا
محتملا لترامب وهو وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق مايك بومبي الذي لم يستبعد
امكانيات ترشحه ويملك بومباي وخبره كبيره
بعدما كان شغل حقيبتين مهمتين وهما وزاره
الخارجيه اضافه الى تراسه وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه بطبيعه الحال
هذا ولا يزال ترامب وديسانتس المرشحين
البارزين
والرئيسيين حتى الان وقد يواجه ترامب
تحديا حقيقيا من حاكم فلوريداب بعدما احتل
الاخير المرتبه الاولى في استطلاعات
الترشح للمره الثانيه على التوالي في اقل
من شهرين
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا المذنب
الاخضر يقترب من الارض لاول مره منذ 50
الف سنه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تطبيق جديد يلوح في
الافق قد يخزوا العلم الافتراضي فبعد اكثر
من اربع سنوات من غياب مؤسسي خدمه
انستغرام عن الساحه هذا مجددا مع تطبيق
جديد يوصف بانه سيكون التيك توك الاخبار
على احدث تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي في
منشور على انستغرام
مع فريق منذ اكثر من عام على اطلاقه هذا
التطبيق واضاف انهم بداوا اتاحت التطبيق
للمستخدمين تدريجيا كما من الممكن الان
لاي شخص الانضمام الى قائمه انتظار لتجربه
التطبيق فماذا يميز هذا التطبيق الجديد
بخلاف انستجرام يركز التطبيق الجديد
بالدرجه الاولى على المقالات بدلا من
الصور حيث يقدم ارتفاعك توصيات بالمحتوى
بناء على الاهتمامات وسيعرض الموجز
الرئيسي للتطبيق الجديد المقالات الشائعه
من المؤسسات الاعلاميه الكبرى بالاضافه
الى المدونات الاخرى حسب تفضيلات المستخدم
ووفقا لما ذكره موقع بلاتفورمر الذي كان
اول من كشف عن اطلاق هذا التطبيق فانه
سيسمح بالمناقشه مع الاصدقاء ووصف الموقع
تطبيق الجديد بانه تيك توك للنصوص وربما
يشكل خطرا مفاجئا على تويتر وتساعد ميزات
التطبيق المستخدمين على الحصول على
الاخبار بشكل موجز مع الحفاظ على سرعه
تداول مقاطع الفيديو مثل تطبيق تيك توك
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من الرياض
عبد الله السبع الباحث في الشؤون التقنيه
يا طاهر اهلا فيك عبد الله همم معنى همم
شو تصورك اللي مثل هكذا خبر همم عند
التطبيق الى اي مدى تجد يعني انه في له
همم اليات حقيقيه وانه سينتشر
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه تطبيقات الاخبار
احنا نحتاجها من فتره طويله يمكن ابل بدات
من فتره عندها تطبيق الاخبار الخاص فيها
لكنه ما انتشر انتشار جدا كبير في سنوات
الماضيه يمكن انتشر على فئه معينه من
الناس يقدروا يطلعون على الاخبار لكن كما
نص اجتماعيه مجانيه تقدم للاخبار
المستخدمين بطريقه احترافيه اتوقع ان
التطبيق راح راقي رواد جدا كبير يمكن بس
همم الشيء الوحيد اللي احنا لازم نعرفه
انه مستخدمين هذا التطبيق راح يكون الفئه
العمريه مختلفه عن بقيه منصات التواصل
اجتماعيه وهذه تراميزه الناس تبحث عنها
بتحتاجها وترى الان في الفتره الحاليه صار
في حب عند الناس عند القراءه صار فيه حب
واتجاه جدا كبير الاطلاع على المعلومات
وقراءتها لذلك اذا طلعت تطبيق يقدم للناس
مقالات دوريه مقالات سريعه يمكن الوصول
لها مع مقاطع اتوقع راح يرجع ثوره
المدونات اللي كانت موجوده في سنوات
الماضيه لكن المدونات كان ينقصها شيء
واحده من انت لازم تدخل المدونه وتقراها
وتطلع من المدو
نه وفح موقع لكن يجي تطبيق يعطيك اخبار
يعطيك مقاطع فيديو ويسهل على الناس قراءه
المقالات والاخبار اتوقع راح يسبب ثوره
كبيره وراح يرجعها حب الناس القراءه خلص
الناس اللي تحب تقرا بعض المقالات الادبيه
اللي ما تتجاوز مثلا صفحه صفحتين
عبد الله اللي هذا التطبيق
هل ربما سيشكل يعني او نشاهد هجره من
تويتر همم الى همم ارتيفاكت يعني خاصه بعد
التغييرات الجذريه التي حصلت في عهد ال
الماسك عندما استلمتر يعني هل سيكون هو
البديل
والله ما اتوقع لسبب واحد تويتر عند
القيمه المضافه والقدره ان يصنع منصه خاصه
بالاخبار ترى لازم نعرف انه ماسك الشهر
القادم تقريبا راح يطلق ميزه انك تقدر
تنشر تغريدات همم باربعه الاف حرف تقريبا
وهذه تقريبا ممكن تنافس منصه الجديده اللي
مجمع اطلاقه في الايام القادمه وهذه صراحه
اتوقع انه راح تشكل لتويتر وصول سريع جدا
للمستخدمين وايضا امكانيه تجربتها اتوقع
المنافسه في هذا المجال راح يكون جدا
لصالح المستخدمين ومن فائدتهم بشكل جدا
كبير تويتر
يمكن مثل صلاح قلنا
[موسيقى]
مهم جدا سواء في الشاشه وفي منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي
من الرياض تحياتي اليك رئيس المركز
الامريكي باول يقول ان مستوى التضخم فوق
المعدل المستهدف ويتحدث عن انه المركز
الامريكي بحاجه الى المزيد من الادله
للتيقن مما اذا كان التضخم يتراجع او لا
وبناء على ذلك يقرر المركز لاحقا اذا كان
سيرفع الفائده من جديد ام لا لانه معدلات
فائده يعني التضخم ماذا لا مرتفعا
وبالتالي لم يصل بعد الامريكي الى انه
معدلات الفائده يعني تخفف هذه المعادلات
التدخل على الرغم من حصول المقدسي اكرم
عميره على ترخيص بناء من بلديه القدس
اسرائيل الا انه فوجئ صباح اليوم باغلاق
القوات الاسرائيليه مدخل بلدته وبيته وهدم
منشاته دون سابقه انتر ذلك بعد اصدار
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي قرارا هدمي
14 منزلا ومنشاه فلسطينيه في القدس
[موسيقى]
وعقاب جماعي لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه على حساب
الحقوق الاساسيه للمدنيين هكذا يصف
الفلسطينيون اصدار تعليمات لهدم 14 منشاه
ومنزلا للفلسطينيين والتي تم تنفيذ سبع
منها في حي الطور وسلوان وجبل المكبر
ومناطق اخرى تعتبر حساسه واستراتيجيه في
القدس
انا دارك فيها رخصه وتاهتها
انا جاي اه مشكل في حكومه اسرائيل ما في
عليه
السلطات الاسرائيليه بهدم منشات لانها
بدون ترخيص لكنه منشاه المقدسي اكرم عميره
تم هدمها على الرغم من حصوله على رخصه
بناء من بلديه القدس التابعه لاس
ودفعه رسوم الرخصه باهظه الثمن الا ان
وزاره الداخليه اصدرت قرارا بهدمها حسب
القانون احنا حملنا حالنا ورحنا حسب
القانون وجبنا اللي هو الرخصه هي
الترخيص حسب القانون
وبرضو ما ساعدش وانا ماشي ولما بنيت حسب
القانون اجوا فحصوني لا يقتصر الهدم على
منزلا او منشاه فقط بل على احياء كامله
مهدده بالهدم والاخلاء مثل حي بطن الهوى
في سلوان جنوب المسجد الاقصى في القدس
المهدد بالهدم لاستبداله بحدائق توراتيه
لصالح المستوطنين
هنا في قريه صور باهر في القدس تهدم
القوات الاسرائيليه منشاه لفلسطين قيد
الانشاء بعد اوامر وزير الامن القومي
المتشدد اعتمر بني كبير بهدم 14 منزلا
للفلسطينيين في القدس على الرغم من
المحاولات العربيه والامريكيه بالتهدئه
لان كل غاصي من القدس العربي
[موسيقى]
طلال مداح الذي رحل قبل اكثر من 22 عاما
تحت عنوان ليله صوت الارض وفي هذه الصور
المباشره يشارك في الحفل الذي ترعاه هيئه
التافه السعوديه اكثر من 40 فنانه عربيه
من ثلاثه عشره دوله لتكريم الفنان الراحل
الذي امتد عطائه الفني لاكثر من نصف قرن
الراسخا في ذاكره السعوديين والعالم
العربي
[موسيقى]
حبيبي يا حبيبي
كتبت اسمك على صوتي كتبته
دارك وحبيبي يا حبيبي حبيبي
[موسيقى]
بصراحه شيء يثرج الصدر ويخلي الواحد عاجز
عن عن التعبير بصراحه شي يفخرنا صوت الارض
الراح الكبير طلال مداح في يوم تكريمه
هو يوم تكريم لجميع فنانين السعوديه
والعرب بشكل عام يعني انا ممكن من اكثر
الناس سعاده وفرح
بتكريم الاستاذ طلال رحمه الله عليه لاني
انا يمكن عاشرته فتره طويله امتدت الى 32
سنه قدم لي فيها في بداياتي الحان وقدمت
له الحان ايضا
وعلاقه طويله يعني يمكن يبغى لها حلقات
عشان احكي عنها لكني سعيد
وفرحان الليله بهذه الليله الكبيره
[موسيقى]
مبادره رائعه فعلا الى صوره اليوم الان في
العربيه 360
بصمتها هيتقدات الى تجمد قوارب الصيد بسبب
توسع مساحات الجليد البحري
الالاف من قوارب الصيد بميناء مدينه
داليان وهي متجمده فوق سطح البحر تنتظر
ذوبان الجليد والثلج للشروع في رحلات صيد
الاسماك
مساحات جانبيه ضخمه بلغت ما يقرب من 13000
كلم مربع
وفي تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 تصريح
اليوم ربما يعتبره الفرنسيون الصادما لانه
خرج من رئيسهم السابقوند
الاسلحه خرج بتصريح لصحيفه يقول ان الرئيس
الروسي بلادي ميربون ليس على العكس بوتا
عقلانيون الى ابعد احد حتى
تتعب من دعم اوكرانيا وتوافق على انهاء
تفاوضيا للصراع سيكون في صالح روسيا
فيديو اليوم من العربيه 360 ظاهره يشهدها
عالمنا اليوم للمره الاولى منذ 50,000 سنه
سيكون المذنب الاخضر قريبا للغايه من
الارض وكانت المره الاخيره التي اقترب
فيها من الارض خلال العصر الجليدي الاخيره
بحسب العلماء وسيتمكن سكان الارض في
المناطق التي لا تعاني من التلوث الضوئي
من مشاهده مذنب سيظهر للعين المجرده بوضوح
الليله وغدا
المحاوله
لرؤيه جمال الكون والاستمتاع به
شكرا لمتابعتكم العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار
ساعه لا تنقطع مع صهيب شراير الان مساء
الخير صهيب مساء الخير رؤيا وطاهر صحيح
بعد قليل مستمرون في متابعه اخبار هذا
اليوم جولتنا السريعه الشامله والمتنوعه
اخبار الساعه وفي الصداره اوكرانيا تشن
هجوما على اله المناطق بسبب ما تقول انه
همم عدم وصول عدم السماح بوصول التغريدات
المؤيده لاوكرانيا على تويتر اليك شكرا
لكم
[موسيقى]